Now I'd like to introduce
our speakers today.
Professor Huggy Rao is
a professor of organizational
behavior at the Stanford Graduate School
of Business.
He teaches courses such as Human Resources
Management, and some executive programs
with Stanford and Human Resources,
as well as customer relationships.
He is widely published in the field
of management and sociology, and
studies the social and
cultural causes of organizational change.
His recent work investigates
the role of social movements
as motors of organizational change in
professional and organizational fields.
Huggy, welcome.
>> Thank you.
>> Our second speaker is
Professor Robert Sutton.
Bob Sutton is a professor
of Management Science and
Engineering in
the Stanford Engineering School.
Sutton is also co-founder of
the Stanford Technology Ventures Program,
and of The Hasso Plattner Institute of
Design, which is a multidisciplinary
program at Stanford that teaches and
spreads design thinking.
He is an IDEO Fellow,
a member of the Institute for
the Future's Board Trustees, and
consults widely with many organizations.
Sutton studies the links between
managerial knowledge and
organizational action, innovation,
and organizational performance.
He has received many honors,
including named as one of10 "B-School
All-Stars" by BusinessWeek in 2007.
So, I've listed kind of both Huggy and
Bob's many achievements and
things that they've done.
But the other thing is that
they work a lot together, and
have spent a lot of time writing books
together and doing other things.
And so, it's always fun to be
engaged in conversation with them,
which is what we'll be doing today.
So with that,
I'm going to turn it over to Huggy.
>> All right.
Good morning everybody, welcome to this
webinar on reducing organizational drag.
First, I wanted to welcome Bob as well,
who so graciously set aside time,
and what we thought of is both of
us would actually have a conversation
on reducing drag in the organizations.
Again, some additional context,
one of the things that Bob and
I find very useful is as we
are developing new ideas.
We find conversations to actually
be the gateways to understanding.
Sitting by myself, at least I can think
about things, having a conversation
with Bob, I find it open up new doors,
new avenues and the like.
That's why we thought we'd actually
have a conversation with both of them.
>> I would also add that your
questions are especially important,
both because we get a sense of how
everybody who is watching this feels, and
also, it gives us fodder to respond to.
>> Right.
>> So, we
especially appreciate your questions and
comments.
>> Absolutely.
After Bob and I wrote this
a book on scaling up excellence,
one of the things we thought we really
needed to think and develop tools,
and Bob spearheaded the idea of a project
on designing organizational change.
And part of the goal of that project
is to have actually understand drag and
friction in an organizations.
And what I wanted to do was to
take a little bit of your time,
present some simple facts about
friction to set the stage.
And then what we will do is, Bob and
I will have a conversation
about what causes friction.
What are some ways maybe to mitigate them?
We hope to hear from you about your tools,
techniques,
ideas that you might have as well.
First, friction in organizations.
We all have visceral
understandings of friction.
When there is friction, there is noise.
Sometimes there is heat.
There is grinding.
There is also frustration at
an emotional level, and maybe fatigue.
But from the individual point of view,
let's give you some data on drag and
friction in organizations.
One study by Rob Crossman and his
colleagues found knowledge workers spend
80% to 85% their time attending
meetings and responding to requests.
Instantly, that tells you where
friction can lie right there.
In the same study,
they found that leaders,
when they delegate things to their
subordinates, they underestimate by as
much as 50% the collaboration burdens we
actually place on their subordinates.
So, delegation isn't simply delegation.
You're also placing coordination
burdens on your subordinates.
And another form of friction,
of course, I guess is email, and
one other study of a mid-size firm showed
that if you assume, it cost 95 cents
to process an email for this medium
size firm, it costs a million dollars.
Let's turn to the organizational view.
[NOISE] Let's actually turn to
the organizational view in just a minute.
>> Getting some adult supervision here.
>> Thank you.
Yeah.
So, in organizations, friction often
is manifested as interruptions.
In one ethnographic study by Mark and
colleagues, they followed 36
executives for half a day.
And stunningly, they found the average
amount of time an executive spent on
a task before being interrupted was
three minutes and five seconds.
In another study,
people spent 12 minutes and
18 seconds on a work
domain before switching.
And surprisingly, people interrupted
themselves 44% of the time,
often in response to a question,
a request or a proposal by somebody.
One other problem of friction is
something called attention residue.
The psychologist Leroy and his colleagues
found that when people move from one
task to another, the previous task
has conceptual or cognitive overhang.
And you actually have to unburden
yourself of that overhang before
you concentrate on the new task.
And all of that actually
depletes ability and performance.
And finally,
the organizational effects of friction.
The more friction in organizations,
employees might quit because
of damaged work life balance.
There's also, speed is impaired,
and we lose agility and speed.
And we, of course,
don't get the opportunity to innovate or
do something called deep work that
requires extraordinary concentration.
So, this is really the background
about friction and drag.
And just to let you know, we're going to
use both of these terms interchangeably.
Some of you might, in the questions,
suggest there are differences.
And we, we're very open to what
those differences indeed are.
So, let me quickly, without further ado,
invite Bob into the conversation.
Bob, when normally one thinks of friction,
one usually thinks of persons.
And normally, one thinks of ****.
Is that the only source of
friction in your organization?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Or are there other sources?
>> Well, for those of you who don't know,
for better or worse.
The reason Huggy's asking this,
I wrote one, and
I now I'm writing another book about
the problems with **** in organizations.
But I think actually, that's too crude
a term [LAUGH] in a couple of ways.
And to me, there's two parts of this.
First of all, what we're doing, and
what we're trying to do is to
really focus on not just friction
as something you do to yourself, and all
of us, maybe we could be more efficient.
I mean,
there's Is books on like essentialism and
how if you just managed yourself better
you'd have less friction in your life but
we're real interested in how groups and
organizations cause friction.
And we'll keep talking about that and we
would love your ideas about the causes and
the cures.
But on the **** thing,
there are particular sorts of people and
they may, or may, not be ****,
that I think are especially
prone to cause trouble in organization
when it comes to friction.
And then, there are people who
are especially prone to get rid of it.
And this is one thing that we've been
noticing in the various organizations,
including the company
Stanford that we work at.
That you will have two people
in very similar positions
who they magically under the same set
of rules, the same set of constraints,
they find ways to clear the way and
things are easy to do.
And then, there are other people who for
them personally it's difficult to do it.
To get things done, and when you go to
them and ask for help, they make things so
complicated that everybody around
them gets dragged into this vortex.
And you can sort of say that there
are some people who are like WD40 and
some people who are throwing sand,
and there is some specific research
that might be relevant on
toxic people who add friction.
A researcher from New York University
actually called these Rule Nazis and
these are the kind of people,
and we have them at Stanford and
every large bureaucracy I've
ever worked with has them.
They are people who,
when you go to them with any problem and
they get seven times more complicated
then it perhaps needs to be.
They pull in all sorts of people,
they are constantly worry about
everything goes wrong so it takes
nine times longer to get things done.
And one of the things
we're interested in is
what are the situations that attract and
breed Rule Nazis.
Because that behavior actually might
be because they're scrutinized so
closely by the system
they make the mistake.
They just get slammed.
It may not be a personality variable.
And then, what are the of hallmarks of
people in systems that are able to get
around and do things easily.
So there's a whole bunch of other
organizational causes we might want to
talk about.
But one of the things we're interested
in is, so what is the difference between
people in groups who seem to easily get
things done, and remove friction from
the same system, same set of constraints
versus making everything difficult?
>> I love the idea of the Rule Nazi.
I hope all of you can, of course,
quickly search your memories and
identify the Rule Nazis in your life.
I'm curious, Bob, since you mentioned
the two individuals you know,
one kind of person clears the way and
the other person kind of follows rules,
would you think that
the psychological characteristic of
openness has anything to do with
whether anyone's a Rule Nazi or not?
So in other words,
are open minded people less of Rule Nazis?
>> Well there’s openness,
I also think that with at least, and
Heather Halverson is the one who
did this research by the way.
That people to use this
cool word Rule Nazis,
people who tend to be so
anxious about making a mistake, and
perhaps have been slapped down so
severely for making a small mistake.
They also tend to be
quite anxiety-prone too.
That that's the way Now, their kind of
person might become petty dictators.
Sort of the way they gain control of
others is by throwing up difficulties.
To move away from **** and
negative personality types.
One of the things that I'd be curious from
some of the people who are watching this
to hear if this is something that
comes up in your organizations.
I actually think that, although it's
always interesting to talk about
personalities and
they're always very big in our world,
some of the things that happen in
organizations that cause friction we're
both interested in, or when they create
incentives for people to add friction.
So one of the things that we've noticed
at a number of organizations that we have
worked with is there'll be all sorts
of incentives for you to add a program.
So that if you have a new program,
a new idea, a new initiative.
But you get glory for it.
And that everybody at our
organization gets glory for doing it.
Even if you just sent emails.
Like it might create the appearance or
the actual reality that you're doing work.
And the more people you send it to, the
more people know that you're doing work.
But there's this thing,
and it's sort of like the,
in economics they call it
the tragedy of the commons.
Were the incentives that help you
individually get ahead in your career and
make a mark and be known,
it just adds more and more and more load?
At Stanford, just for example,
we have a new set of teaching
evaluations at Stanford, and the committee
on it worked on it very enthusiastically,
and so what they did is
the created a situation where,
wow, I've gotta spend a couple
more hours a year dealing with it.
I had to go to a meeting
to learn about it.
And I honestly don't think the new system
is any better than the last system, but
all the people involved in doing it,
they get more glory.
So I guess that's good.
So that's one kind of incentive where
everybody has incentives to add, but
not to subtract.
And we all suffer from the weight
of more and more and more programs.
And the other thing is, I don't know
what it's like in your organization, but
in many organizations that I work with,
the amount of pay grade that you have,
your levels of pay grade, this is
certainly true in the civil service.
The more people report to you,
the more you get paid.
So there's all these incentive for
people to build kingdoms.
And the way that adds friction is when you
have more people, you have sort of more
administrators and maybe more faculty
members or more direct workers.
Who add more and more load on one another
because size almost always adds friction.
So although I think there
are some personality types
where my mind tends to go
with this problem is what
are the incentives in the organization,
that unwillingly cause friction and
one of them is a, each one of us when we
throw something out we get reward and
nobody gets rewarded for
getting rid of something.
And then,
the second one is this idea of sizes and
this is a big thing that our books getting
up excellence which is Which is size,
is almost always causes more friction and
bad interpersonal relationships,
the more people you add to a problem.
>> I think what's kind of very
striking is Bob has identified one of
the important Is that leads to friction,
and that is incentive.
And I very much like your point, Bob.
That the incentives are asymmetric,
i.e., you're rewarded for
adding, but not for subtract.
Adjunct being the case in point.
But the way I also thought you described
the tragedy of the attentional condenses.
Perhaps when one copies everybody
indiscriminently on the mean,
is that like another example of something?
Damaging the commons,
the attention on commons.
Now, Bob and I went into an executive
program recently with one C as you recall.
Said that the person who actually
kind of copied me on an email.
If they found out that
person is going to be fired.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [INAUDIBLE] Are punishments the only
way to deal with damaging
the intentional comments, or
are there other more mischievous ways?
>> Well, I don't know if there
are more mischievous ways, but
certainly at least removing incentives for
people to add friction and
giving them incentives for
them to get rid of it at the very
least is actually Not a bad idea.
Another organizational design feature,
and this is controversial.
So I'll say this and see if we get some
reactions out of folks is everybody talks
about how great transparency is,
and how all we gotta share,
we gotta tell everybody what we're doing.
Well, there is an argument that I don't
need to know everything you're doing and
you don't need to know
everything I'm doing.
In fact, it just overloads me with
literally more junk on my mind and
the more that's on my mind
the worse I do on my job.
And if you go to the extreme case to
the most secretive organization on earth,
it's not the CIA, it's Apple computer,
at least that I know of.
And there's an interesting argument and
Huggy and I have talked to insiders and
of course if we used his name they
would have to shoot us, because,
it's much easier to get information
about the CIA as we've seen or
with the NSA with all the leaks and
everything.
But Apple, there's been no breach yet, and
one of the things that we know about Apple
very well is they are extremely secretive.
And outside of the small,
immediate team you work on,
nobody is allowed to ask anybody,
to know anything, their employees badges
only let them in a very small part of
the organization even quiet senior people.
And although there are some
disadvantages to that level of secrecy.
We could talk about those, I mean Apple,
aren't they the largest most successful
company in the world right now.
I think they're back to number one,
it always makes me wonder there's some
coordination issues and the like, but
to me that shows the positive
advantage of secrecy.
Because one of the reasons is,
they just have less cognitive load,
they just have less friction.
They just get to work on
whatever they're working on,
and they can't even know what's
going on in the rest of the company.
>> We have a related
question from the audience.
>> Thank.
>> Also somewhat controversial.
So one person is asking about
collaboration and teamwork.
It's often a value that many companies and
managers hold very dear.
But is that also potentially
a cause of friction or drag?
>> Yeah, there's a real
interesting study about this,
do you want to talk about that?
>> Sure.
So who was the person
who asked the question.
>> I don't know, I can find out.
>> Because that is
a really good question and
we need to-
>> Karen.
>> Karen, thank you for that question.
>> Great question.
>> That is a very good question.
The short answer is, yes,
collaboration is a burden.
And if you've forgotten
everything from this webinar and
maybe you want to remember just sort
of one thing, and the one thing is
think about how collaboration actually
burdens your best performers.
For the sake of this argument let's assume
each one of you listening to our webinar,
we'll assume that each one
of you has 100 subordinates.
Let's further stipulate, out of the 100,
that 10 are at the very top.
Now, in general and
I'm making a very gross generalization,
please correct me Bob if I
strayed off the reservation here.
On a general basis,
if you have ten high performers, one would
assume that five of them, they're great
performers, but they're high maintenance.
They want raises, they want recognition,
they want attention from you.
Loosely we can call them [BLEEP] because
they're never likely to be grateful.
>> That's sexist, but it's okay.
>> I'm sorry.
[LAUGH] Now, the other five are people
Rob Cross and Adam Grant would
refer to as the extra milers.
And that's the study-
>> The givers.
>> The givers Bob was alluding to.
So when you think of the extra milers,
this
is the other half of your top performers,
the remaining five in your top ten.
These are not only your high performers
but they're also the most helpful people.
They respond to everybody's requests for
collaboration and help and so forth.
And it turns out in a couple of studies,
when they receive more than 24 requests
in a week or so, they begin to harbor
thoughts of leaving the company.
The extra milers, they're so
cooperative their main problems is that
they don't know how to say no and
as a result they seem the most disengaged.
Indeed, we might argue that for
many of you listening to this webinar,
if you at the end of this webinar have any
new ideas, whom are you going to turn and
entrust them to, your extra milers.
It's very unlikely you're actually
going to ask your [BLEEP]
to kind of help you out, you're going to
ask your extra milers to do this.
And so what you're doing is
you're putting more friction and
more collaboration burden on them while
they're the ones being burnt out.
Do you agree with me?
>> I agree with you but I would also go
back to the organizational consequences.
Because the study which Adam Grant and
Rob Cross did is very interesting.
because it's essentially showing that
there's a small percentage of people who
take the lion's share of the burden for
collaboration, and
they allow everybody else
to do what they want.
And so givers like that give so much that
they burn out and it's really a risk,
but I also go back to the organizational
causes and consequences.
Because if you are in your team,
if you are a senior executive who
is into organizational design and
incentives, if you reward both,
let's call them the free riders
instead of using the “p” word,
as much as you or more than you
reward the ones who are givers.
Then there's something wrong with
who you're giving an incentive to,
who you're promoting.
So a lot of this goes back to
organizational process and
we may blame the sort of people
who are doing the free riders,
but if they've been rewarded for it,
if that's the kind of people you attract.
If those are the kind of people you
promote it's actually rational behavior
for you to do the work for me,
and to go to all the meetings and
do all the collaboration, while I just
focus on building my star power and
we get rewarded equally or me even more.
It's partly an organizational issue too.
>> But you know I hope this can
clarify your question, Karen.
But the other thing, I just want to
quickly jump on what Bob mentioned about
the organization side is, often,
when I work with executives and
ask them, what do you think we
should do about the extra milers?
And indeed I urge all of you to think of
giving a gift to the extra milers when
you go back.
Your own extra milers on whom
you heap cognitive load and
the burdens of collaboration.
Usually executives kind of think of
things like we've gotta work with them so
that they delegate more.
That seems sensible but the one
thing with extra milers we know is,
if you take away anything they feel that
there's a reduction of their role and
their importance.
And they're not too happy with it.
The other kinds of things that people come
up with are we'll give them a day off, or
we'll give them an evening off.
Instead, the things that we found
that help these extra milers,
is not giving a day off,
because they all like to work.
It's actually giving the day off,
free from interruption.
That's the kind of reward that
we are actually thinking about.
So you come to work,
you're doing your work but
nobody's bothering you, firing a lot
of questions and asking you for
help so that you harbor thoughts
of leaving the organization.
So, did that help, Karen?
>> Yeah, it seems so.
She did ask, is there an optimal
mix of givers and free riders, etc.
>> That's actually a much more difficult
kind of question to answer because
the optimum mix of givers and takers is,
you can easily exhaust the supply of
Givers and it's the number of takers-
>> They can tolerate.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah.
>> So you know, it is also interesting,
and this is, again, a more organizational
design approach, that I don't know about
the optimal mix of givers and takers.
Adam Grant, who wrote the famous book Give
and Take, wonderful guy, he would say
the optimal mix is, how he implies it
is like 100% givers and zero takers.
But life's not going to work that way,
I don't think, in the near future for
any of us.
But one of the mixed things that I think
also really affects friction which is just
now occurring to me, but something that
Huggy and I have both thought a lot about,
is the percentage of people who
are specialists versus generalists.
Because, you know,
my wife who used to be a lawyer used
to joke that a generalist is somebody
who knows everything about nothing.
No, no no.
Nothing about everything.
And a specialist is someone who
knows everything about nothing.
In organizations,
I think that the biggest risk,
as opposed to givers and takers, is having
too many people who are generalists.
And it's funny, because I think
I'm pretty much of a generalist.
Because when you have people who are
generalists, what you have is a bunch of
people who feel obligated to get in one
another's spaces and tell them what to do
and what they ought to do, but actually
don't really know that much about it.
So they do just enough to
insist on reports or new ideas.
But they actually don't know
how to solve the problem.
So my perspective I guess this let's us
get back to organizations like Apple.
And I think of Netflix,
which I know a little bit,
which actually has a lot of specialists
and is a well-run organization,
is you need just enough generalists to
know how to glue everything together.
But once you have excessive generalists,
you start having people who throw
in friction because they think
they know the answer to things that
they don't know the answer to.
>> That's an excellent point, Bob.
I mean, this idea of generalism and
specialism.
I think it's not only incentives but
also the depth of capabilities.
[CROSSTALK].
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> That's a really well taken point.
I haven't thought about it.
I'm also keeping track of time.
We focused on incentives as
a source of drag and friction.
What about ignorance?
And here, and
the reason I sort of ask about it is-
>> That gets you,
that's related to generalists.
That's interesting.
>> Yeah,
that's exactly why I was touching on that.
Because as you said,
the generalists were ignorant.
But more broadly what
I was thinking of was,
ignorance as a source of
friction in organizations.
And I'm reminded of a study by our
wonderful colleagues Dale Miller and
Deborah Prentice where what they did
was they asked Stanford undergrads,
what is your private attitude
towards the consumption of alcohol?
And, individually,
Standford undergrads said they didn't
approve of drinking alcohol on campus.
But, on the other hand, when they asked
the very same Standford students, what do
you think is the attitude of the average
Standford student for consuming alcohol?
Their view was that the average Stanford
student actually was very permissive
in terms of his or
her tolerance of alcohol.
And you, is that the kind of ignorance
one needs to worried about here?
Here it's pluralistic-
>> It's pluralistic ignorance.
Well, that's one kind of ignorance,
and certainly that's a problem,
and obviously alcohol at
Stanford is a huge issue.
You've been watching the news.
But to me the worst sort of
ignorance is when ignorance and
arrogance are brought together.
And this is the classic
time when friction, and
other horrible things
happen in organizations.
So when powerful people think that
they know how everything works and
then they come in and
start telling other people what to do.
And you have that in your slide deck
where when people, when superiors
assign jobs to subordinates, they tend
to underestimate how long it will take.
Classic problem that happens.
But yeah, certainly ignorance
is a cause of friction.
And as with all management, and this is
something that I talk about in Good Boss,
Bad Boss and talk about in a lot of
Stanford Executive Programs, is that
the hallmark of a good boss, and this is
something that will reduce friction, and
it's the opposite of ignorance, is knowing
what it feels like to work for them.
And having enough empathy, sympathy and
understanding of the people that they
lead, that they know when to get in
their face and tell them what to do and
they know when to back off.
Either because they don't need the help or
actually by getting in,
they'll be making things worse.
So this is one of those cases
where self-awareness is one of
the cures to this malady.
>> Right, and Bob's point about
self-awareness being a cure to
the malady again is well taken.
Because in this very same Stanford study
that both of us mentioned moments ago,
what was the solution?
Clearly, individual students
thought drinking was a bad idea.
But they mistakenly thought that
the average Stanford student actually
was much more tolerant.
Which was a complete myth.
And the quickest way to solve that was to
provide each one of them feedback to show,
hey, other Stanford students like you
also personally disapprove of drinking.
And that actually led to a big
drop over the next six months
in terms of drinking on the campus.
But I want to pursue another interesting
image that your previous comment
evoked for me, Bob.
The image that your comment evoked for
me is a small coterie of powerful
people thinking they know everything.
Arrogance, or simply confidence.
And then the rest of the organization,
I sort of thought of them as more
Doubting Thomases in your imagery.
So when is doubt a source of friction,
and how is that different from ignorance?
Is it the same thing, or?
>> Well to me ignorance
is when you have the confidence
to go in and tell
people what to do even though you don't
have any idea what the heck you're doing.
Because you're in a powerful position and
you know better.
And at Stanford just because,
I don't know,
you're a world class electrical engineer.
That means that therefore you're an expert
on organizational design or anything else.
Which is this idea of the sort
of right stuff mentality.
But doubt is not so bad.
Because if it's doubt where people stop
and think about what they're going to
do before they do it, because they think
they don't have enough information or
there might be a problem,
to me that's constructive doubt.
Because it's the kind of doubt that
Danny Kahneman talks about when you
face an important decision.
You slow down, and
instead of making a bunch of mistakes,
you actually think about
what you're going to do.
And we, a lot of us believe
in rapid prototyping and
all that sort of stuff,
and to learn by failing.
But the hallmark, to me, of people who
have the right amount of doubt and
the proper amount of confidence
without being destructive is,
what they do, is they find a little
place to do an experiment rather than to
do something really stupid
that ruins everybody's life.
And the example that I use, and
I'm sure that many of you've been
involved in large IT rollouts.
U Stanford, again, our history for
large IT rollouts is not too impressive.
And one of the reasons that there's
problems with large IT rollouts is that
some allegedly very smart people tend
to come up with the perfect solution.
And then roll it out across campus,
and then their incompetence and
overconfidence introduces massive
amount of friction and frustration and
fatigue for literally thousands of people
who can't deal with their new IT system.
And if instead they had done some
prototyping, some developing, being in
a small sort of pilot are and really
really got it working, and then spread it.
There would be much less friction for
everybody in the larger system.
So that's where to me
actually having some doubt.
That maybe it isn't right and
maybe it isn't ready for a 100,000 or
10,000 people to use it.
Is actually a proper
way to reduce friction.
So but
when you get to the point where you're so
insecure that you can't act,
that's a dangerous sort of doubt.
>> I'd like to sort of quickly sort,
quick, yeah, more questions?
>> I have one question
that I think is related.
So Rudolfo Aguilar is asking,
what about trust and friction.
Does lack of trust create friction?
>> That's a great question, Rudolfo.
>> Nice question Rudolfo.
>> I think your question is a wonderful
sequel to the question on doubt.
And what Bob was describing as
constructive doubt if you will.
But the moment you use
the word distrust and
I find that kind of interesting,
because distrust means suspicion.
And suspicion essentially means one is
questioning the motives
of the other person.
And the moment that you begin to question
the motives of the other person,
clearly the opportunity for
friction kind of multiplies.
So a great example of friction
caused by distrust often is
during the integration of new
acquisitions in an organization.
I mean, what you actually have is
an enormous amount of friction then.
In fact,
I would argue that if your company, for
instance, is acquiring another company or
being merged with another company,
a very useful way to reduce friction would
be right at the due diligent stage itself.
Identify a series of hundred-day
improvement projects.
We're going to bring in accounts
receivable from 15 million to 2 million.
We're going to actually improve
the answer time on the phone calls
when the customer counts come like five
seconds to two seconds or whatever.
Obviously, I'm making up these numbers.
What those kinds of projects do is
they actually give focus to people and
they allow people for
both the acquirer and
the acquiree to actually work together and
to overcome mistrust and distrust.
So that's the advantage of doing that.
So the short answer is distrust
indeed is a big cause of friction.
>> The other thing, Rudolfo,
I think you're really onto something
because the only thing I think about with
distrust is with distrust comes suspicion
and actually justified paranoia.
That you're so worried about being hurt,
about being surprised that you do a whole
bunch of very, very time consuming,
sort of CYA activities and
I even talk about this when I work
with people who have abusive bosses.
I tell them to do a whole bunch of things
that add friction which is to document,
to go around and check things off.
To build a group of friends you don't
really need except to support you and
I'm thinking even of some organizations
where there's really low trust cultures,
including one that Huggy and
I worked with years ago.
When I first met you, we were
talking to fairly senior executives.
And they described how when there was
an important meeting, there always had
to be seven or eight pre-meetings
that people have in smaller groups.
To make sure that no one, and this is like
a relatively moderate size company but
there is so much fear and paranoia even
in senior levels that you have seven or
eight pre-meetings before
the real meetings.
So there was no surprises so
that you personally weren't in
a position to be hurt by others.
So that you worked out
the politics before.
And to me, that's a real sign of mistrust,
the fact that things have to be done
backstage, and in fact,
I talked to a CEO about
the most destructive members of his top
management team and I won't quite swear.
He called them grim f-ers,
is what he called them.
And these are people who in the meeting,
they really,
really smile at you and
agree with everything you do.
And then they run around and
stab you in the back.
And he said when that happens, it just
creates a whole bunch of, not only fear,
that's also another problem, but friction.
It just adds all this
friction to the system.
So I think that to your point,
I think that friction is a real,
distrust, mistrust, paranoia,
which is sometimes justified,
is a real strong sort of undercurrent
that causes these problems.
because people have to protect themselves.
It's not irrational.
>> But listen to what's also
interesting is the confusion also
is a consequence of distrust because you
never know why something happens or not.
Quickly summarizing, we've actually
identified a number of sources of drag and
friction in organizations.
One was incentives.
Another was actually rules.
The third was inequality or
power differences, that Bob alluded to.
The fourth, of course, is distrust.
And one takeaway for all of you,
thanks to Karen's question,
is remember, don't go back and
put more burdens on your extra milers.
These are the people helping you,
don't shoot yourself in the foot
by giving them more to do.
Because you're going to frustrate them,
they're going to be fatigued,
they're going to leave the organization,
you'll damage yourself.
We have a little time and
I want us to kind of quickly
investigate another possibility.
Is friction always bad?
Are there times when we should
create friction in organizations?
What do you think Bob?
>> Well I think friction is good,
under some circumstances.
One is, there are some situations
which are really big situations.
But things like an acquisition decision.
Whether or not to lay off people.
Having some process where people
are actually forced to think
about what they're doing.
And there's also another
reason where something
that might feel like
friction might be important.
Which is that sometimes to do things
with enough humanity so it doesn't
hurt people and it actually fuels
things like trust in the organization.
You’ve got to sort of slow down and keep
things in a somewhat less efficient way.
One of the classic thing for
the back to the **** question.
I've got, actually I get this once a year.
Somebody works for a company and
somebody in HR wants to fire
people by sending them emails or
text, rather than doing it in person.
And it's more efficient.
It gets rid of friction.
But if you want to create
fear in an organization.
And, large scale cases, RadioShack,
at one point, fired huge amounts
of people by sending them e-mails.
So, maybe this might add friction, but
I think or get rid of friction, but
it creates so many other ripple effects.
This also, just a little design thing and
then we're stop.
A friend of ours, Michael During,
who was head of Ebay North America,
he's now a venture capitalist.
He used to make this argument,
that in the early days of eBay,
I don't know what's going on in eBay now.
There was a big argument between the pure
IT type user design folks who just wanted
everything to be as easy as possible to
get in and out of eBay with your purchase.
But Michael's an old retailer.
Actually ran a huge retail
store when he was in his 20's.
And he said the way retail works is,
we like to sort of slow things down.
And show things to people along the way.
That because they might buy them and
slow them down.
And if you've been to IKEA and
I'm sure many of you know IKEA.
That's just the whole theory of the store.
It takes forever to get out of the store.
And they just show you all this crap.
And you throw all this stuff in your
cart that you maybe didn't want in
the first place.
So there might be times when people,
at least for capitalistic reasons,
you want them to slow down, and
also human and decision-making,
those are the things that come to mind.
>> Yeah, those are very nice examples,
Bob, I want to pick up on the IKEA one,
as well.
What I heard Bob saying, hey,
you might really need friction
when you actually want curiosity and
commitment.
>> Now that's interesting.
>> That's kind of what I got
from what you just said.
And the IKEA experience
is an interesting one.
Because in marketing there's this
thing called the IKEA effect.
In this study, what they showed was if
you ask somebody to pre-assemble some
kind of shelf or whatever it is for you,
as opposed to you making it yourself.
People who made it themselves and
experienced friction were actually more
committed and were much more satisfied.
The people who got something made,
they only kind of were able
to identify the defects.
That wasn't done properly,
this wasn't done properly.
They were still in the consumer mode,
and not in the producer mode.
I'm kind of wondering,
should organizations actually create
friction right at the stage of hiring?
>> Well, that's kind of interesting,
because you're making me think
this is a double-edged sword,
because a lot of what Huggy's talking
about is the psychology of commitment.
That a lot of organizations
make it difficult to be hired,
to sort of run you sort of a gauntlet
in the early days in the organization
because it actually does
increase commitment.
So the friction increases commitment.
But the thing I don't like about that is
that you have a bunch of people who went
through a very difficult, high-friction
experience, and they feel obligated,
I did it, so I'm going to do it to you.
And so you end up with this sort of-
>> Vicious circle.
>> Sort of vicious circle,
where everybody adds more and
more friction, and in some ways-
>> That's really nice.
>> It isn't just friction, it's load.
Where you actually see this in a specific
case, as many may know, that for
medical residency, surgical residencies,
and so on, that the residents
tend to work 90 plus hour weeks.
And it causes all of these physical and
mental health problems and
is really hard on the profession, and
they keep trying to get rid of it.
And they actually haven't been very
effective at getting rid of it in
part because the residents who
are now doctors, attending physicians,
and so on, they say I did it and
I'm going to do it to you.
And so there is that sort of,
in this case, cycle of friction and
abuse and load, that the prior
generations do on the new generations.
Because they did it and
they want to maintain the-
>> This is a-
>> Justification-
>> This is a really fascinating idea Bob.
The reason I find myself fascinated by
your argument is, this happens when we,
of course, have these conversations,
I do get fascinated.
But what you just said
when you were saying this,
it reminded me of Dale Miller's
work on moral licensing.
And Dale's argument when he does
this experiments on moral licensing,
is that if you do a good deed, that is,
you donate 50 bucks to a non-profit,
you are more likely to run
through a red light or
a stop sign because you
think you're a good person.
>> You're a good person, yeah.
>> Then you license
yourself to do bad things.
But just in this lovely
account that you gave me,
I never sort of thought about it that way.
It's sort of like if you've
been a recipient of friction,
you're going to be more morally
licensed to impose it on other people.
I find that really quite-
>> It's justifying your identity
and existence.
>> Right,
that's actually very interesting.
>> I'm going to ask Bob and
Huggy to take a few more questions.
So one question that we had come up
from a few different participants is,
does a small company necessarily have
less friction than a large company?
What is the relationship between
the size of the company and
the amount of friction within it?
>> That's a great question.
Here's my quick, sort of, take on it.
I think it was in one of the programs
that maybe Bob and I were running,
or I forget when I met this executive.
I asked this person a simple question.
I said what's the difference between
a startup and a large company?
And here was this person's answer.
He came back and he said well, professor,
he said small companies have big people,
and the larger the company
the smaller the person, and
that hopefully gives you an idea.
It's not that there's no
friction in a startup,
there is indeed friction in a startup.
But what you actually have is
this sense of mission analogous,
which overrides that.
My nephew works in a startup, and
I won't mention the name of the startup.
I ask him, what's it like?
He told me,
he said it's like a labor camp.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Working all the time!
So there is a lot of friction there too,
but people don't feel as frustrated and
as fatigued as in a larger corporation,
would be my wager.
>> So to piggyback on what Huggy said,
I think the evidence says, and
back to Michael Dearing I
already mentioned,
who moved from places like eBay and
the like to now he's done early
stage financing for more than
a hundred startups, very successful.
And he'll argue that speed is the only
real advantage that startups have.
But I would sort of add as
a caveat that the worst situations
are when companies use to be startups and
they get bigger and bigger and bigger.
And management is in denial of the fact
they need some control mechanisms,
they need some hierarchy.
They need some process,
some specialized roles.
And they don't accept
that they've grown up and
have to deal with the fact
they're a larger organization.
And it's actually, interesting example,
GitHub, which is now doing incredibly
well, went through a period where they
just wanted to be a big startup and
not have any controls and
let everybody do what they wanted, and
it led to some pretty ugly stuff.
They got rid of one of their CEOs and
brought up another guy who's much better.
And the first thing he did was to
start a process of actually adding big
company-like controls,
because they became big enough that
acting like a startup didn't work at all.
So, yes, startups have less friction
than large organizations, but
the worst situation is when you
pretend you haven't grown up.
>> So another question that we have
received is, can you share, and
I think you've shared a few examples
during the webinar, but are there
really good examples of companies who
have been able to create a culture
that has less friction, or have been able
to very effectively reduce friction?
>> A good example that Bob and
I wrote a case study about was Adobe where
they actually dropped their performance
appraisal system because they found out
they were spending 90,000 manager hours.
They weren't getting anything.
So they certainly have taken friction out,
but at the same time, given that they have
yanked the system out, people are actually
yearning for, what do we do instead?
Can we actually develop
something much more lightweight?
The other solution I would recommend
to people is be mischievous.
Think of having the words like MVP for
the person who copies everybody
on every email that they receive.
Nobody would want to-
>> A little friendly humiliation?
>> A little friendly
humiliation is a good thing.
Or MVP, the person who attends
the most number of meetings.
Things like that, you can actually be
a little edgy and you can do that as well.
So that's another thing to do.
But the most important thing
is before you do anything, you
might really want to ask yourself or Pose
the friction and drag test for yourself.
How is what I'm doing,
how is that causing fraction.
So, let me close with
one quick example and
this was an example of a large
multinational company.
They wanted to reduce costs and
the person who didn't think much about
friction quickly pulled up an Excel
spreadsheet and said, my God,
our sales guys in Germany all have
Mercedes sedans leased to them.
We can reduce costs by giving all of
them cheaper Volkswagens instead.
They partly reduced costs.
But later when this executive flew to
Germany, one of the sales people told him,
do you know what you did?
And the person said, well, we just
reduced cost, we took the Mercedes out,
we gave you a VW.
He said,
you have no idea what you've done.
He said, look at me, I'm a salesperson,
I drive home in the VW.
My spouse looks at me and
thinks, my god he's in trouble.
The children kind of ask me,
dad what happened to the Mercedes?
My neighbors begin to give us strange
looks thinking is the family in trouble
at the firm.
And he looked at this executive and
said that as a sales person,
what's the most important thing I need?
And this executive said, confidence.
And then the sales person said, what have
you done with my confidence with this?
You've actually lowered it.
To this executive's credit, he realized
it and then discovered that the bottom of
the company in Texas, and there were
a lot of smokers in that company.
And that's when he realized that the
better to launch an anti-smoking campaign
there and reduce the insurance
premium rather than yank the car out.
So, it's a good idea
before you do anything ask
yourselves how much friction
am I going to create.
And to Bob's point, some of the friction
that you create may not be visible
to you when you make a decision.
>> Yeah, so
I would add just one little thing.
This company is actually cut,
I think of like Amazon and Walmart.
Which are not the nicest companies to
their employees in the world, by the way.
And I've worked for both of them.
So, I'm biting some hands that feed me,
but that said, they are organizations
where really there is a focus on both
frugality and making things easier to do.
And then I would just add just a word
from someone who teaches in the SI&E
program who's one of my charismatic
heroes the young Jeremy Utley.
What's the name of the course he teaches?
>> Empathize and prototype.
The fact that he says and
I teach with Jeremy and
Jeremy is the perfect friction reducer.
One of his motto's whenever
we're planning lessons or
thinking of anything is I hate
wasting other people's time.
And I think that-
>> There you go.
>> I see that in how he makes decisions.
In all sorts of ways, always thinking of
how can I make things less burdensome for
my students, for the executives I lead,
for the companies I consult to?
And I think ending on Jeremy's motto and
just to really hate and
try to figure it out, how not to
be disrespectful of other people's
time might be a good motto for all of us.
>> With that I want to really
thank both Huggy and Bob.
I am very much hoping that
you enjoyed this hour and
that we didn't waste your time and
our time.
[LAUGH] And that you learned
about some valuable insights and
I encourage you to check out any of
our offerings at scpd.stanford.edu.
All of you will receive a recording to
this webinar to share with your friends
and colleagues, and
have a good rest of your day.
>> Thank you.